[Musique]
bonjour mon nom est stefani allison
grave je suis une personne trans en
transition qui est très impliqué dans la
communauté lgbt et plus particulièrement
auprès d'un organisme qui s'occupe des
personnes trans qui s'appelle la sécu je
suis ici aujourd'hui pour vous parler de
trans identité
mais avant de vous parler de trans
identité j'aimerais vous dire comment
vous et moi on a grandi pour devenir les
personnes qu'on ait aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes né il ya eu un docteur une sa
chambre
et quand d'autres qui vous a signé un
genre que c'était soit un garçon ou une
fille en fonction de ce que cette
personne doit constater de vos organes
génitaux
on vous ensuite attribuer un prénom puis
les pronoms qui étaient conséquents avec
ça c'était le premier chef aux combes
unis sur la tête pour vous aussi en tant
que personne dans société
quand vous êtes arrivé à l'école aux
primaires
vous êtes aperçu que quand on rentrait
dans un groupe scolaire se conformer aux
croyances aux idées de ce groupe là pour
avoir des chances de succès dans les
lits un puck tort quand vous êtes arrivé
à l'adolescence
vous vous êtes aperçu qu'il ya des
choses commencent à se fixer dans votre
vie dans des cars que ce soit la langue
quoi que ce soit d'autre mais aussi
l'identité de genre
par exemple le m pour masculin puis le f
pour féminin rendu à l'âge adulte
ces règles sont devenues pour vous
complètement parfaitement intériorisé
tellement que c'est extrêmement
difficile de penser le monde autrement
que sans ces règles là moi je suis né
dans les années soixante dix dans ces
années là c'était très difficile d'être
une personne avec une orientation
sexuelle une identité de genre ou une
représentation son genre différent de la
nomme les personnes qui s'affichait
autrement a été vite sommes souvent de
mac
ou même dans certains cas de violence
puisque les plus dérangeants ça c'est
que s'était renforcée par la famille par
l'école puis même par les étrangers puis
ces gens-là nous rendait l'addip la vie
difficile
sans même s'en apercevoir la transe
nativité est difficile à assumer dans
notre société parce que elle n'existe
pas elle provoque chez les personnes
trans qu'on appelle la dysphorie de
genre 10 forêt vient du grec et veut
dire difficile à supporter si le livre
d'une personne devient trop difficile à
supporter à cause de son genre ça peut
se transformer en ce qu'on appelle de la
transphobie intériorisé la transphobie
c'est le fait d'avoir peur des personnes
trans ou d'être mal à l'aise dans leur
présence
donc une personne qui vit de la
transphobie intériorisé ce sens
extrêmement mal avec elle-même et
chathuant engendrer des conséquences
extrêmement graves
le plus étrange dans tout ça c'est que
les personnes trans sont pas si
différents de vous c'est juste que c'est
comme un faux départ le genre qu'il
aurait été assignés à la défense elles
sont comme vous ce sont des diplômés des
ouvriers des employés
les employeurs des entrepreneurs mois
mind je suis parents de trois enfants
puis je n'ai outin de métro boulot dodo
comme peut-être la majorité d'entre vous
j'écoute les mêmes films que vous
possiblement les mêmes séries peut-être
avec des préférences différents et aussi
je fais à peu près les mêmes activités
que vous la vie d'une personne trans est
vraiment semblable à votre vie quand on
fait un coming out
c'est à dire qu'on décide d'extérioriser
ce qu on est à l'intérieur
il faut que la personne trans est
consciente qu'il faut qu'elle apprenne à
se redéfinir dans la société
elle sait très bien que la société ait
pas nécessairement prête le genre
d'existence qu'elle veut avoir
c'est vraiment un redémarrage à tous les
niveaux que ce soit au niveau financier
ça peut entraîner de graves pertes
financières des pertes d'emplois et que
ce soit au niveau administratif comme le
changement non plus toute la paperasse
que ça peut impliquer que ce soit au
niveau social via certains de nos amis
les plus proches qui peuvent nous
rejeter parce qu'on est devenu trans
même ça peut être la même chose aussi au
niveau familial et a plein d'autres
niveaux
c'est pas un choix d'être ans on l'est
puis le seul choix qu'on a en tant que
personnes trans
c'est de la fumée ou non souvent le
coming out
c'est un choix ultime entre la vie et la
mort pour la personne trans maintenant
c'est vraiment difficile pour une
personne qui est pas transmis de
s'imaginer ou de se mettre à notre place
en fait c'est inimaginable tout les
problèmes les petites choses de la vie
qui peuvent devenir compliqué juste
parce qu'on est trans par exemple moi si
je décide d'appeler à la banque pour
faire une vérification sur mon compte de
banque
ça se peut que le préposé qui soit à la
quand je dis je m'appelle stefania
leeson avec la voix que j'ai il fasse
les vérifications un petit peu excessive
puits supplémentaires si je veux aller
faire un voyage aux douanes ça peut être
la même chose je peux même dans le pire
des cas me faire accuser du sur passion
d'identité plus au quotidien
si je décide d'aller faire une sortie
d'une journée au complet à l'extérieur
il faut que je prévois détruit aussi
banal que des toilettes neutre pour
éviter d'aller dans les toilettes de
genre et parce que il pourrait arriver
un gardien de sécurité qui me sortir des
toilettes féminin même si je suis une
femme mais d'origine transe
alors comment qu'est ce qui arrive avec
notre société c'est que la france n'en
citer fait pas partie
de fait pas partie de notre société
c'est quelque chose qui est pas gérer
du tout dans la société alors comment
qu'on doit agir devant une personne
trans cancon et pas sur comment
s'adresser en fait c'est bien ça que
vous lui demandez lui dit tu dois je
m'adresser à vous au féminin au masculin
ou autrement
oubliez les papiers d'identité gardez en
tête que la personne trans devant vous
cherche pas à vous berner ou à vous
cacher quoi que ce soit hr jeu ça
projeté à l'extérieur ce cas les à
l'intérieur donc la nature ne fait pas
de différence entre la culture la classe
où la langue les personnes trans ne se
définissent pas strictement par leur
identité de genre
elles sont aussi diversifiés que la
majorité de la population
quand vous savez sur terre il ya
plusieurs menaces à l'humanité les
guerres les iniquités sociales et
changement climatique peut vous rassurer
que la transidentité c'est pas une
menace à l'humanité même personnellement
je crois que c'est une partie de la
solution acceptée même mesure est
intégrée la différence dans notre
société ne peut que nous enrichir
en tant que société gardait toujours en
tête qu'au final on et vos collègues de
travail on et vos voisins on et vos
cousins cousines vos frères vos sens vos
parents vos enfants on est comme vous
car si beaucoup
[Applaudissements]